hey 7 i'm a little bit sick today but i
am doing a review and answering youtube
comments because that's what I love to
do so today i'm answering a question
from one of my youtube viewers tech deck
talk time who are doesn't say hey would
you mind checking out my channel i
leaving a comment telling me what you
think what I might do differently it
would be much appreciated things so I
loaded up the page here this is the page
of the top and the first thing my first
bit of advice here is we got to focus I
come to this page I don't know what I'm
getting and I'm not really curious to
learn more right so either tell me what
I'm going to get up here or even better
make me feel something right out I want
to come to your page and say wow I'm
really curious to learn more I don't
know what this is all about so tech deck
talk time is long it's hard to say i'm
assuming you're some kind of technology
you know v lager you're going to be
going to tell me about new products
coming out some kind of technology but I
shorten it up and keep me focused you're
telling me I get new videos every
Saturday but I don't know what you're
talking about I don't know what the
subject of the videos are and you know
the two pictures of you it's great but
it's not it's not making me want to
learn more so I'd focus this a little
bit more tell me what I'm gonna get or
even better make me feel something when
I land on this page if we go to the
about page it says here we review things
like songs and movies and tell you what
I think about them okay so I don't know
how that relates to tech but songs and
movies okay fine and then I go back to
the video page and you've got things
like you know tips for freshman summer
break review so that it's not a movie I
don't know RP Robin Williams what else
you got here Donna planet of the apes
dance recess so there's some its a mix
right it's not that many videos here but
you know your main video is talking
about tips for freshman your page at the
top is talking about tech and you're a
bell page is talking about movie reviews
so it's kind of all over the place and
if you're making a lifestyle channel
around you that's fine just make that
clear right so focus this in so i know
what i'm getting and can have a pleasant
experience and following you the next
thing I do is have this video here
introduce yourself so five tips are
freshmen is probably not the best way to
start especially if most of the stuff
you're going to be doing is about movies
then this is totally out of character
and it's okay to have some of these on
your channel doesn't have to be all
super focus but especially is your main
video you want to be related to what
you're usually talking about so I
neither have it as a movie review but
ideally it's a hey I'm you know whatever
your name is it doesn't say what your
name is here to stay on the about page
no okay so put your name on it but you
can you know introduce yourself and tell
me what I'm going to get on this channel
why it's so great you know give me some
more information and just having one
video here that is about a specific
topic that's not what you usually talk
about and then the other thing I would
say is you got to post more frequently
so we've got this video from three weeks
ago or then to its ago and one month ago
and this was two weeks ago you know I
watched a bit of this video and it's
fine it's okay for anybody starting
YouTube channel okay it takes time to
develop your style you got to figure out
what your style is you're going to watch
a bunch of other people's videos and
channels and take bits and pieces and
try something and it's going to be
uncomfortable at the start and you just
it takes a while to find your voice and
your style and what how you want to
create your videos and that comes with
practice so if you want to really turn
this into something popular something
that you can be proud of something that
can potentially make you a full time
income art n be odd you need to get more
practice like once a week is not enough
you got to amp this up you got to be
doing something every day just like
anything else you know you want to get
better at baseball you gotta go on
practice every day you want to get
better at math you got to go out and do
your homework every day you got to
practice you want to get better videos
once the week isn't enough you had to do
something every day to develop your
style you know and and try new things
take some
risk with it until you develop a point
where like wow I'm really I'm really
happy with what I've done so far okay so
lose your three tips what focus to make
this video an intro video make it better
and three make your videos come up more
regularly practice practice practice
those are watching you like the video
you can subscribe to the channel you can
support me by clicking on the link in
the description and I'll leave a comment
let me know you think your comments mean
a lot to me and help me keep this travel
going so thank you and we'll see you
soon